you're on this show stranger things and
you're trying to help them out yeah
you're trying to yes exactly they
struggled terribly if your season and
they thought this guy could bring is
wrapped in anonymity and then they
thought we need to rise or magic for
season two let's see if I can't tank
this yeah yeah this is stranger things
probably one of the biggest hits of last
season you've come into the show now
were you a fan of this show before you
joined it yes I was yes I was
don't think I wasn't because I was I
didn't imply oh wow I actually because
my son is very hip I got in I got early
on the curve it dropped on a Friday last
summer and like that Monday my son said
if you heard of this new show I said
dumb because oh it's great I've seen all
eight episodes I said that's why you
haven't done any homework you watched in
a time yes yes that's what they do now
yeah but literally he told I said I'll
have to check it out and ten minutes
later I get a call from my agent he said
are you familiar with the show stranger
things I said yeah of course I don't
live in a cave yeah I keep up one thing
yeah because the guys want the duffer
brothers these geniuses yeah they said
they want to meet you they have a part
they think you would be great for so I
said sure and I literally met them right
there I but then I hurried I before I
met them I watched like four so you
binge watched i binge watch sure I don't
binge I cuz an hour show I can't binge
more than two and then nap takes over I
just like no matter how good the show is
like - yeah and then three then you'd
need like a pee break and a meal break a
meal penalty you gotta break it up a
little bit but I was familiar and versed
and these guys are like the geniuses
they're really cool smart guys
you